أسوأ مخاوفي هي أننا نتسبب في
إحداث ضرر كبير للعالم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه إذا حدث خطأ في هذه التكنولوجيا ،
فقد تسوء تمامًا ونريد أن نكون
صريحين بشأن أننا نريد العمل مع
الحكومة لمنع حدوث ذلك
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أننا سنحتاج أيضًا إلى
إرشادات قواعد حول ما هو
متوقع فيما يتعلق بالإفصاح من
شركة تقدم نموذجًا يمكن أن
يكون لديه هذه الأنواع من القدرات التي
تتحدث عنها لذا فأنا متوتر حيال ذلك
[  الموسيقى]
من أكثر المجالات التي تثير قلقي ،
زيادة القدرة العامة
لهذه النماذج على التلاعب لإقناعها بتقديم
نوع من
التضليل الفردي ، كما تعلمون ، معلومات مضللة تفاعلية
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
نؤمن بها بشدة ونتصل بها
من أجل التنظيم الدقيق للذكاء الاصطناعي
لسنوات حتى الآن ، هذا ليس
منصبًا جديدًا نعتقد أنه
يجب نشر التكنولوجيا
بطريقة مسؤولة وواضحة